يريد ان يتعامل بلطف مع بكين بوليسي قالتو
مؤسس شركه يامل بان تجد رسالته المؤيده
للصين تاييدا اكثر مما كانت عليه عام 2020
الملياردير يخوض ترشحه مبكرا لانتخابات
رئاسيه بالغه الاهميه العمل المقبل من
شانها اعاده تشكيل النظام العالمي كما
تقول
اعلن الشهر الماضي انه سيسعى للحصول على
ترشيح للرئاسه التايوانيه من حزب المعارضه
الرئيسي في البلاد كومنتانج مقدمه نفسها
على انه افضل مرشح لتجنب الحرب مع الصين
فشل غو في الفوز في الانتخابات التمهيديه
لحزب كومنتانغ عام 2019 ثم ترك الحزب بعد
ذلك وتنقل
هيسياو المدير التنفيذي لمعها تايوان
العالمي ومقر واشنطن قوله ان الملياردير
غو يصوروا نفسه على انه النسخه التايوانيه
لكنه على عكس ترامب لم ينجح جو بعد في
محاوله الفوز بالرئاسه حيث يقول خبراء انه
بعيد المنال هذه المره ايضا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات